ahora que ya hemos entendido lo que son
las conformaciones de silla y bote vamos
a ver si podemos descubrir cómo es que
una conformación silla se convierte
justamente a una conformación bote y de
hecho una conformación bote también se
va a convertir en otra conformación
silla así que digamos que este de acá
este este primer carbono va a ser
justamente el carbono número 1 este
sería el 2 el 3 el 4 el 5 y el 6 muy
bien ahora vamos a proseguir poniendo un
sustituye ente digamos que tenemos aquí
un grupo metilo 1 ch3 que está unido a
este anillo ciclohexano ok entonces este
es un anillo ciclohexano mono sustituido
aunque íbamos a poner justamente ese
grupo metilo ahí ahora bien podemos
darnos cuenta que
que para pasar digamos a esta imagen que
tenemos a la derecha simplemente rotamos
un poquito está esta figura hacia la
izquierda verdad más o menos en este
sentido de tal suerte que que es lo que
obtenemos obtenemos que aquí está
nuestro nuevo carbono número uno aquí
está el dos tres cuatro cinco y seis
verdad simplemente giramos un poquito
está esta conformación y dónde quedaría
nuestro grupo metilo quedaría aquí
verdad se h tres quizás debería ponerle
un poco más a la derecha para que se vea
claro que estamos uniendo al carbono
verdad ahora bien lo que vamos a hacer
para llegar a nuestra conformación bote
es lo siguiente digamos que vamos a
agarrar nuestro
vamos
vamos a agarrar este carbono de aquí
vamos a agarrar este carbono el número 4
y lo que vamos a hacer literalmente
vamos a jalarlo hacia arriba
vamos a jalarlo hacia arriba y qué es lo
que obtenemos que justamente este ahora
queda de este lado muy bien ese carbono
rojo es el que el que es el número 4 y
entonces si este era el 4 el 1 que da
igual el 2 también el 3 se estiró un
poco hacia la izquierda aquí que del 4 5
y 6 verdad entonces ahí tenemos nuestra
nueva conformación ok así fue como
llegamos de silla a bote
donde queda nuestro grupo metilo pues
sigue igual verdad es así que no se
movió ahora lo que sigue es este primer
carbono este primer carbono vamos a
igualmente estirarlo ya jalarlo para que
llegue hasta esta posición de tal suerte
que ahora se encontraría aquí mientras
que nuestro carbono 4 se encuentra por
acá arriba entonces qué es lo que
tenemos ahora nuestro carbono 1 se
encuentra aquí abajo el 2 que el 3 y el
4 el 5 y el 6 donde queda nuevamente
nuestro grupo metilo pues el grupo
metilo queda justamente aquí verdad y
finalmente simplemente volvemos a rotar
un poquito en este en este sentido a
esta molécula para obtener que este es
nuestro carbono
2 3 4 5 y 6 nuevamente vamos a marcar el
grupo metilo ahora se encuentra un
poquito más arriba verdad así que ya
hemos convertido una conformación silla
en una conformación bote de esta forma
pero al mismo tiempo hemos llegado a
otra conformación si ya de hecho lo que
hicimos fue ir de una conformación silla
a una conformación semi silla o medio
silla ok
digamos un poquito bote torcido y luego
pasamos a un bote completo luego a un
bote torcido y luego terminamos
nuevamente en una conformación silla y y
simplemente lo que hicimos fue mostrar
todos los cambios principales que hay
que hay que digamos por los que hay que
pasar para ir de una conformación silla
a otra conformación silla ahora
nuevamente esto lo puedes ver con tu
modelo molecular o tu equipo de mujer lo
molecular que lo puedas ver en tres
dimensiones y es creo la única forma de
entenderlo
ok y bueno entonces qué es lo que pasó
con este grupo metilo
este grupo metilo déjenme marcarlo con
con otro color este grupo metilo ch3
inició siendo axial y en la dirección de
hacia arriba verdad está apuntando hacia
arriba y además de todo era axial
después en este paso sigo xxi yo
apuntando hacia arriba en todos lados
aunque siguió apuntando hacia arriba sin
embargo al final ya no es axial verdad
hubo un cambio ahora sigue apuntando
hacia arriba sigue apuntando hacia
arriba pero ahora es ecuatorial ahora
éste sustituye ente fue ecuatorial
por ejemplo qué pasaría si tuviéramos
otro sustituye ente digamos aquí mismo
en el hidrógeno ponemos perdón en el
primer carbono ponemos un hidrógeno
entonces si nos damos cuenta en este
caso tenemos que es ecuatorial verdad en
este caso al ir cambiando resulta ser al
final que ya no es ecuatorial sino ahora
es es axial pero en la dirección hacia
abajo había iniciado hacia abajo terminó
hacia abajo pero empezó a ecuatorial y
terminó axial ok entonces una vez que
tenemos un sustituye ente que empieza
axial y digamos que está en una
conformación silla que se convierte en
otra conformación silla se va a volver
ecuatorial a este proceso es a lo que
conocemos como inversión del anillo
vamos a escribirlo de hecho esto es el
proceso de inversión
anillo del anillo se refiere justamente
al anillo de átomos de carbono que
tenemos
y de hecho algunos estudiantes piensan
que esto significa que literalmente solo
volteamos el anillo verdad y esto
realmente no es lo que está ocurriendo
de hecho estamos convirtiendo bueno
podemos convertir de una conformación sí
ya la otra y viceversa verdad entonces
qué es lo que pasaría bueno ya vimos qué
pasaría si empezamos con un sustituye
ente ecuatorial en resumen lo que
podemos observar es que si empezamos
axial terminamos ecuatorial y si
empezamos a ecuatorial terminamos axial
verdad
sin embargo lo importante es que se
mantiene hacia arriba o hacia abajo
relativo al plano al plano digamos del
anillo que vimos en el vídeo anterior
verdad ese es el concepto de la
inversión del anillo así que vamos a ver
si podemos practicar dibujando algunas
con formaciones de este ciclo hexano y
vamos a ver la conformación silla que
tenemos hasta arriba a la izquierda
vamos a ver vamos a partir de este
ejemplo
y lo que podemos ver en este ejemplo es
lo siguiente bien pensemos en el enlace
que tenemos entre el carbono 2 y el
carbono 3 si nos damos cuenta este es
paralelo al enlace que tenemos entre el
carbono 5 y el carbono 6 verdad que otro
podríamos observar que tenga este patrón
bueno el enlace que tenemos entre el
carbono 5 y 4 es paralelo al enlace 12 y
finalmente el enlace 16 es paralelo al
enlace 34 de hecho es por esto que
muchos alumnos piensan que que parece
como una especie de una especie de rayo
verdad es la figura como como de un rayo
así que en realidad toma mucha práctica
dibujar estos carbonos en una
conformación si ya realmente tienes que
practicar mucho y tienes que empezar
haciéndolo lentamente así que vamos a
ver si podemos dibujarlo lentamente aquí
abajo
vamos a ver tenemos un enlace por aquí
un enlace por aquí y tengo otro por acá
muy bien
entonces este enlace se conecta con otro
y éste tiene que ser paralelo a ese
ahora este que sigue tiene que ser
paralelo a cuál tendría que ser paralelo
a este verdad entonces sería como algo
así y finalmente el restante tiene que
ser paralelo al inicial verdad entonces
más o menos obtuvimos algo por el estilo
y ahora lo que sigue para dibujar la
conformación de este ciclo hexano la
conformación silla de este ciclo hexano
tenemos que pintar todos los enlaces que
están en una en un arreglo axial verdad
entonces ponemos por ejemplo partimos de
nuestro primer carbono aquí sería
nuestro primer carbono y en el primer
carbono ponemos un enlace que sea axial
hacia arriba ahora ya vimos que el
patrón que sigue es uno hacia arriba uno
hacia abajo no hacia arriba o hacia
abajo entonces en el segundo tendremos
un enlace que va hacia abajo en el
tercero axial hacia arriba en el cuarto
axial hacia abajo en el quinto
hacia arriba y en el sexto acz
hacia abajo verdad
ahí lo tenemos y ahora tenemos que
continuar con los enlaces que son
ecuatoriales entonces y aquí ya había
uno que iba hacia arriba el ecuatorial
que va en el carbono uno tendrá que ir
hacia abajo verdad entonces este sería
ecuatorial hacia abajo después
tendríamos ecuatorial hacia arriba en el
segundo ecuatorial hacia abajo
arriba ecuatorial en este caso va hacia
abajo
ecuatorial iría hacia arriba muy bien
entonces ahí tenemos una conformación
silla del ciclo hexano
y de hecho recordemos que teníamos
nuestro grupo metilo en el en el primer
carbono así que vamos a ponerlo aquí de
esta forma tenemos nuestro carbono y
tendremos nuestros tres hidrógenos
verdad
los tres hidrógenos y ahora bien como
como haríamos para dibujar es esta
conformación si más bien la otra
conformación si ya que tenemos entonces
nuevamente esta idea de que son como
hijos
paralelos más bien red son rectas
paralelas
paralelo a este
y esté ahí lo tenemos ponemos nuestros
enlaces que recordemos que aquí cambian
verdad en el primer carbono ahora
tendremos el axial hacia abajo
tendremos después bueno vamos a pintar
todos los axiales y ya tenemos una
acción hacia abajo axial hacia arriba
hacia abajo hacia arriba hacia abajo
hacia arriba y ahora ponemos los
ecuatoriales y hay uno que va hacia
abajo este tendrá que ir hacia arriba
abajo
tendría que ir algo así luego hacia
arriba
abajo hacia arriba y finalmente hacia
abajo muy bien ahí tenemos nuestras dos
con formaciones y aquí podremos
distinguir que nuestro grupo metilo
ahora pasa a ser de tipo ecuatorial
entonces ponemos el carbono sus tres
enlaces digamos de esta forma y ahora lo
que quiero que analicemos es ver cuál de
estas dos con formaciones que ya tienen
un grupo metilo extra es más estable y
para ver eso podremos fijarnos si
pintamos otros hidrógenos por ejemplo
este hidrógeno de aquí y este hidrógeno
de aquí creo que con eso basta son como
los más cercanos ya que están hacia
arriba verdad entonces si nos fijamos
tenemos esta esta especie de conexión de
hidrógenos que se encuentran cercanos
recordemos que el grupo metilo pues es
bastante voluminoso verdad y tiene estos
estos hidrógenos muy cercanos sin
embargo en el otro caso tendremos los
hidrógenos más cercanos serían este este
y este de aquí verdad tenemos estos tres
hidrógenos que están muy cercanos
y hacen algo así sin embargo lo que
podemos observar del segundo caso es que
el grupo metilo está bastante alejado de
estos tres hidrógenos verdad está
digamos como aislado en cambio en el en
el caso anterior en el caso de la
comprimir conformación si ya uno de los
hidrógenos corresponde al grupo metilo
lo cual hace que haya un mayor
impedimento estético esto hace que haya
más impedimento estético
sedimento
federico es decir y eso va a provocar
que al final de cuentas haya una mayor
energía potencial verdad va a haber una
mayor tensión torsional y lo que nos
está diciendo es que como esta
conformación tiene más energía potencial
entonces es menos estable de hecho la
más estable sería esta conformación de
aquí justamente donde el grupo metilo es
éste se encuentra en un arreglo
ecuatorial verdad tiene que estar en una
conformación ecuatorial así que si
queremos el grupo metilo para que sea
más bien si queremos que esta
conformación sea más estable necesitamos
que el grupo metilo sea ecuatorial ok
eso es para el metil ciclohexano que
tenemos en esta figura ahora
a veces también se dice bueno como este
hidrógeno que corresponde al al grupo
metilo está interactuando con el
hidrógeno que corresponde al carbono 3 y
al carbono 5 a veces se le conoce como
una interacción y axial 13 verdad porque
justamente está interactuando de esa
forma también hay una interacción con el
5 bueno pero como sea que se llame
realmente lo que tenemos es una es un
impedimento estético con la conformación
de la izquierda así que la conformación
de la derecha es mucho más estable así
que siempre que quieras encontrar la más
estable
pon tu grupo digamos voluminoso de tal
suerte que se ecuatorial porque eso lo
pone más alejado de todos los demás
sustituye entes del anillo